well I thought it would be fun to talk
about the problem of playing poker over
the over mail or over the phone no deck
of cards we can shuffle them and I want
to deal you five cards I want to deal me
five cards
it all works nice and fine for face to
face like we are now how do we do this
over the mail you know if I'm going to
put them in envelopes and mail them to
you know obviously I might just peek
I might just switch the hands here
because you've got ace high and I've got
a king high and you know we'll do it
this way I might I might want to put
cards in envelopes and ship them around
and have a fair deal and that's a model
for what we can do over the Internet
then after we see what happens with
postal mail we can try to see can we do
the same thing over the internet yeah
how are we gonna do this so somehow you
need to choose five cards I need to
choose five cards your five cards have
to be different than my five cards you
should know what my five cards are I
shouldn't know what your five cards are
so we're going to add at least a little
bit of pseudo cryptography here that is
locks we're gonna mail you all the cards
so I'm gonna take each card and put it
in an envelope but you're not going to
be able to see them because I'm going to
put a lock on each one so that you can
receive these envelopes in some random
order the way the post office delivers
them now you get an envelope that looks
like this with your name on it of course
it's got a card in it you can't see what
the card is and we'll do that 52 times
so I'll put a card there's the five of
clubs put that in an envelope
lock it up zero okay locked up I'll keep
the key and there's your second card
I've got the key to all of them so we're
gonna have 52 of these in random order
you have no idea what card is in which
envelope and they're all shuffled by
this whole process of getting them to
you in locked
envelopes like this and so you've got 52
envelopes or boxes each with one card in
it they're all shuffled you don't know
the order and you're not gonna open them
you can't open them actually because you
don't have the key to these locks so the
next thing we're going to do is you're
going to ship them all back to me with
an additional lock on each one so you're
gonna put a lock on the other corner of
the envelopes here and then they'll be
double locked and I'll get all the
envelopes back in random order
each doubly locked so let's do that yeah
these locks are just like the original
ones except that you have the key and
instead of me having the key so you've
got the key now you can unlock all these
second locks and we've got them here
these are different colors so we know
these are Brady locks as opposed to Ron
locks you putting black
on the envelopes should be clear these
are your hands not my hands doing the
work here on my knees I'm on these in
mind
I like these problems these are good so
at this stage were at a very interesting
situation we've got all the envelopes
sent to you with a lock on them in this
case the silver locks that I know how to
unlock and now you've taken the envelope
shuffled them up and put your own locks
on each one one black lock per envelope
as you see here and you have the keys
for the black locks I have the keys for
the silver locks and all of these get
mailed back to me it's on random order
52 envelopes each doubly locked well
shuffled and I can open half a lock you
can open half the locks nobody can get
to the cards on their own we takes both
of us to fully open one of these
envelopes so let's go to the next step I
want to give you the card that's in this
envelope without me knowing what it is I
don't know what it is now in order for
you to see it we have to take both locks
off so I can take my luck works fine
now we have an envelope with just your
lock on it and I can mail that back to
you I don't know what the card is you
receive this in the mail and you know
that's one of your cards for your came
to poker and I'll do that five times so
I'll take my keys and I'll unlock five
of these envelopes removing my lock from
five of them in falaqa I'm done there we
go and now you've got all five year
cards I have not seen these cards
whenever I have my hand on these cards
they've been locked with your lock okay
first one good don't tell me you've got
your hand and the next thing we've got
to do is give me my hand and I've got 47
cards doubly locked I pick five of them
out of a pile here's the first one
here's the second one each of them has
two locks on it so I can't open them you
can't open them fully but I'm gonna take
them those are my five that I chosen for
my hand I'm gonna mail them back to you
is they put them in the post stamp for
speedy delivery this is the professor's
hand but I can't see what it is cuz he's
still it's still got his lock on it so
I'm allowing him to see his hand without
me getting to see it
I'll take my looks off so here's the
professor's hand please mail it back to
me here you go so I got my hand and
they're locked with locks that I can
open let's see what I got and then we'll
see who won the last card I've opened up
all five envelopes and I got a hand
almost a flush even but I got ace king
and you've got Queen Jack ten nine oh if
you had an eight you would add a street
yeah yeah what we achieved was playing
poker over the mail we dealt the cards
out in a way that you never saw of what
cards I had I never saw what cards you
had until we finally opened them up but
individually then we can disclose them
or maybe people have a round of betting
first and you can see that yeah I've won
and it was a fair game right even though
we played it over the mail and you think
it might be impossible to play poker
over the mail how do you deal the cards
in fact you can deal the cards as long
as you have locks that only I can open
and locks that only you can open this is
an interesting example of what we might
call a cryptographic protocol we want to
do something over the internet it's got
certain properties you want to achieve
and I think if poker game is is
emblematic of lots of other things you
might want to have happened with bidding
or other kinds of things on the Internet
here we hey need to have some special
properties what we call community the
fact that you could put your lock on and
then I could put my lock on and then you
can take your lock off and then I can
take my lock off it's kind of unusual in
mathematics where you sort of applying
one function then applying another
function then undoing the first function
and then undoing the second function so
these operations of locking and
unlocking actually commute with each
other so we can do the same thing with a
bit of math and make playing poker over
the Internet feasible then so we need
some function that represents locking so
a card is no longer a physical card it's
some kind of bit string or number that
represents that card I can still write
it maybe he's queen of spades there we
go there's a queen spades that's a bit
string or character string that
represents that card we want to somehow
encrypt that to give us the equivalent
of adding a lock to it so we got a lock
here we want what what does it mean to
put a lock on that bit string
well I'm gonna apply some function we
can imagine just taking it to some power
okay all right so K is a number I know
so K is my key and I'll remember that
and I'll take that bit string and I'll
raise it to a power
maybe modulo some prime or something
these are big numbers these P might be
a hundred digits t-mike you know like
that so and K could also be a very large
number so these are numbers you can't
guess you can't know we can agree on P
but you don't know K that's just like an
envelope with one lakh on it take the
number that represents the Queen of
Spades and raise that to the K power and
K is a big number here so raising a
number to a big powers itself an
interesting operation turns out to be
something that's one of the most
important operations in cryptography and
it's something you can do efficiently so
even if K is a hundred digit number or
200 digit number we can do this very
quickly taking the remainder mod P at
every step and ending up with a result
which is just Q to that K power modulo P
so remainder after dividing by P that's
what this is the computer representation
of it this is the we had for the demo
with an envelope that's the first
encryption we've done that just by
raising to a power and dividing the
results by P taking the remainder so now
we want to raise have the other party
encrypt it again and that's raising to
another power so we can take Q to the K
and raise that to some new power J mod P
so the other party knows us another
secret key so J is Brady's key so you've
taken that you've raised it to the J
power so I've taken the me confusing
them but you sent me yeah you've taken
that raise that to the J power divided
by P taking the remainder and so this is
the result we have the nice thing about
this is you know we can take the locks
off in either order here we can actually
take these exponents off in either order
as well after I get this result this is
equal to by the laws of exponents q to
the J to the K mod P fully equivalent
they're mathematically identical K can
be on the inside or could be on the
outside J times K it's the same as K
times J commutativity of multiplication
gives us exactly what we need here so
now we've got this so you sent me back a
doubly locked value Queen Queen to the K
to the J and so now I want to take the
my key off so I can mail you back your
hard so I can just multiply by K inverse
in the exponent Q to the J to the K
raised to the power K inverse so K
inverse we have to compute in a way that
I can explain later but it really is
just the multiplicative inverse of K
when we're dealing in the exponents like
this and so K times K inverse cancels
and we get this is equal to Q to the J
mod P is to say the K lock has been
taken off so
how we take off the first lock and the J
lock remains the key lock has been taken
off and now you can do the same thing to
remove your lock q to the J to the J
inverse there's a value is J inverse and
up in the exponent we take the remainder
mod P and that's just equal to Q because
J times J inverse is 1 so mod p so this
is this and you could get your card
Queen of Spades so this is an example of
what you might call a cryptographic
protocol
so it's an example where I have some
information you have some information we
want to share information there might be
some complicated rules for how we share
information who gets to know what when
that's exactly the kind of thing we have
here that happens all the time for
example it might be an auction we want
to bid it for an oil field or something
like that and cryptographic protocols do
get used for these kinds of things where
we're bidding you have to commit to a
value and then later you have to reveal
the value so it's very much like we saw
here where we lock things and later
unlock them and so on so so that's
another example various kinds of
economic transactions happen all the
time like this
I think auctions are maybe of the most
interesting example same bucket would be
a hot people the computers to do these
huge calculations yeah so there's a
trick here which is called repeated
squaring it's a wonderful trick it
allows raising to large powers to be
done efficiently and computers are doing
this all the time especially in
cryptography let's take an example so
suppose you want to raise Q to the 11th
power so 11 is not a big number
particularly but let's take that as an
example so that's just few times e to
the fifth squared write this Q to v
square the 2 times 5 is 10 times another
Q that gives us 11 Q so that gives us 2
Q to the 11th what I've done here is
I've taken the problem doing two
operations one a squaring operation and
a multiplication I've reduced the
problem to something of sort of half the
size so instead of having to worry about
computing Q to the 11th I'm not worried
about computing Q to the fifth so I can
be Q to the fifth first I square that
and I multiply by Q and I get Q to the
11th thank you to the fifth how do we
get that well that's just Q times Q
squared squared and Q squared
it's just Q times Q so by building a
chain like this increasing by a power
factor of two every time we can build up
very large numbers quickly the number of
squarings and multiplications you do is
just equal to the bit length of the
exponent so if you had a hundred bit
exponent you're sure
doing 100 squarings and hundred
multiplications we were proper attack
big computers he was still taken
thousands of years to factorize that
number into its original prime numbers
now hidden in the details for this code